la nouvelle calédonie joue son avenir
une nouvelle fois après 2018 et 2020
lille s'apprête à voter lors d'un
troisième référendum pour ou contre son
indépendance la fin peut-être d'un long
processus entamé en 1988 accord sur un
début de règlement du problème
calédonien 26 juin 1988 date historique
après des années de conflit entre pro et
anti indépendantistes et une prise
d'otages sanglante à ouvéa re les
accords de matignon sont signés à paris
autour de la table l'indépendantiste
jean marie tjibaou son opposant le
député jacques lafleur et michel rocard
alors premier ministre la sécurité et la
protection de tous doivent être assurés
des actions de développement économique
et social et de formation
seront mises en oeuvre notamment pour
les régions défavorisées
le texte ouvre la voie à une possible
indépendance de lille il prévoit
notamment un scrutin d'autodétermination
d'ici 10 ans qui n'aura au final jamais
lieu à la place encore d'autres accords
qui seront signés en 1998 ceux de nouméa
c'est un jour historique pour la
nouvelle calédonie ces accords sont
signés par lionel jospin alors premier
ministre
le texte s'inscrit dans la lignée des
accords de matignon il prévoit aussi
l'organisation d'un référendum sur
l'indépendance d'ici 20 ans soit en 2018
la nouvelle calédonie ne sera plus un
territoire d'outre-mer elle exercera une
souveraineté partagée avec la république
vingt ans plus tard le 4 novembre 2018
c'est l'heure du référendum pour ou
contre l'indépendance
verdict le nom l'emportent à plus de 56
%
réveiller des marchés en est français on
s'est battu depuis témoin que steph
français mais ce n'est pas fini les
accords de nouméa prévoyait un second
référendum si le non l'emporté la
première fois résultat un deuxième
scrutin est organisé le 4 octobre 2020
et rebelote le nom l'emportent par 53 26
% contre 46 74 % pour l'indépendant dit
les écarts se resserrent mais comme dit
le dicton jamais deux sans trois cette
deuxième victoire du non entraîne
automatiquement un troisième et dernier
référendum verdict ce week end
[Musique]